all right everybody i am hot to trot
because ross is out on assignment today
but with me at the desk
i am the luckiest girl because there is
a very special guest he is a hilarious
comedian and correspondent for one of my
favorite shows all of our favorite shows
the daily show with trevor noah he has
an amazing comedy special imperfect
messenger out next week i've been
watching and loving please welcome the
fantastic royman jr
hello
how you been old friend i mean
good to see you so excited to do this
with you all right well forbes called
you one of the best
journalists in comedy
and
okay i have to say
that as a self-educated person i think
you know if you are a journalist you are
a seeker you are curious journalism is
one of my favorite forms of a profession
and integrity a north star but this is
in your genes yeah
it's a little different though my father
uh up until his death was a civil rights
journalist and you know columnist and he
covered
you know for for radio he covered you
know the vietnam war he was in south
africa during their riots he was
covering the rhodesian civil war my
daddy spent and then the civil rights
movement so my daddy spent like a good
30 40 years at the beginning of his
journalistic career just getting shot at
and beat on for truth
i'm just kicking it with trevor noah on
comedy central like so it's like we get
to go out and do
a lot of the stories and a lot of the
things that are in the same vein that my
father stood for and that he believed in
and i also have older brothers ever in
journalism fighting the same fight i
just get the the luxury of being able to
sprinkle a joke or two in there well i
think since the dawn of satirical comedy
we've all appreciated the spoonful of
sugar to help that medicine go down and
i think the world shifts it shifts in
political years it shifts through a
pandemic it shifts through what is
happening in the culture
and you guys time and time again have
figured out a way to tackle it and i
just i thank goodness for the daily show
thank you so much i really do thank you
well roy would you like to hit some
headlines with me let's do it let's do
it wait first up
well this is really light and fluffy
compared to what we're talking about and
yet it is what everybody's talking about
so that's why we're going to talk about
it everyone's got their eyes on the hot
couple kim k and pete davidson and the
plot thickens kanye west is out in new
york and miami with actress julia fox
and
people are kind of wondering what is
this all about my
personal opinion
is like this is performance art what's
your take i heard somebody say that kim
kardashian and pete davidson absconded
to a tropical you can what i love is
that you can only abscond if you're rich
right
if you broke it's just y'all went
somewhere in bank like that's
but somehow they've obscured it
yes you had sex in a different bed why
are we using these big words
i think in the bigger scheme of things
if pete davidson is happy i'm happy for
him you know that's a brother who has
you know
when you talk about
being young and being in the public eye
and then having to unpack your own
traumas in front of people on stage as a
comedian and then having to deal with
people reacting to how you deal with the
world so if that man has figured out a
way every day to wake up and be happy go
do it when i watched him on snl he did
this um little commentary this little
monologue
where he also said it's been a pleasure
to grow up
with you guys and in front of you guys
and it just i think he just wins us over
time and time again with his humanity
and his flaws and his triumphs and he is
growing up in front of our eyes these
are young people
kanye is this just a man who won his
wife back you tried everything you
didn't try to apologize you didn't try
to please baby come home and now i just
go i what if i be out with another girl
then she gonna get mad
and then after that then it's just you
just got at some point kanye's just
gonna have to like repropose like i
don't know what the solutions are
they're just human beings
you know and if we remember that then
let's enjoy from that perspective
and root people on i want people to be
happy all right
your story
so
next up spider-man no way home is
killing it at the box office it's made
so far almost 700 million dollars making
it the sixth highest grossing film of
all time beating titanic and
variety reports that on opening night
there were two ex-spider-men in the
audience andrew garfield and toby
mcguire snuck into their local theater
to watch the movie with fans they said
it was an extra special moment for them
because spoiler alert
all three spider-man appeared together
in the new movie so they couldn't be at
the premiere because it would have
spoiled everything so drew did you see
the new spider-man i saw it and i just
cried the whole movie i
think i've heard it makes you do this
movie
you know
having done the charlie's angels movies
there is such a power in the number
three and it brought me back to 20 years
ago when i was trying to tell that story
for three girls
and i just wept the whole way through i
loved it i think it's so good and i'm
glad to see it doing this well this
movie
really does it for me everyone says that
it's moving i haven't had a chance to
see it yet my my girlfriend wants to go
with me but she's a couple spider-man
films behind so we got to play catch up
at the house first because i don't
believe in going with you to see a movie
if you ain't seen all the previews i'm
just you we got to see them all in a row
you know i'm a very sequel centric
well
and this one if you don't you don't know
because you really have the when they
show up you're like oh my god which is
brilliant to me that's brilliant because
like marvel like like everyone does
reboots and remakes and marvel's like
just put them all in the same plot how
they just do that next up we've got an
interesting job opportunity i love this
story i brought this to the news desk
food and wine reports that peel island a
small island off the coast of england is
looking for someone to run its pub oh
and double as its king
the position has been filled for over
300 years and there are no other
permanent residents on the island so
whoever applies should have a strong
passion for isolation peace and quiet
well i think we've been set up for
success here
the inauguration involves wearing a
helmet and holding a sword while buckets
of beer are dumped on your head sounds
like the super bowl meets vikings um and
then people come and do like day trips
on the island but you run a pub yeah and
you're the king roy thoughts
[Laughter]
[Music]
why has got to be beer why can't it be
whiskey i prefer whiskey if i'm the king
i should decide what you dump on my head
would you ever do something like this
yeah i i would love the isolation of
that i would one thousand percent like
the i i i don't know if this is normal
or not but like people go what's your
perfect vacation and it's just my
vacation isn't a location it's number of
people yeah and one is the perfect
number
and i'm a father and i love the boy i
know he might watch this but i don't
care one
what's next roy uh finally it's finally
that time of year where we could ask
certain phrases we're all sick of
hearing phrases we want to go away cnn
reports lake superior state university
has released its annual list of banished
words they've taken submissions from
around the world and here's some of the
words that are on their list
wait what
people are sick of that one here's
another one you're on mute hey hey
you're on mute
when are we all gonna figure out the
mute button you have two years of covert
to figure out the music but you know
your mute the microphone has the
ghostbusters slash through
here's here's one that i really don't
like drew
at the end of the day
and
that being said
those phrases are also being banished
for being annoying filler that doesn't
actually mean anything now drew
at the end of the day when it's all said
and done
what phrases do you want to vanish
viral load
um because i don't know about you
but i go to some crazy places every time
i hear that yeah if you type in viral
load on google that's 50 50
that you're gonna get what you was
looking for yeah
but you know just for a second drew i
just want to reconnect and let's circle
back let's circle back to the beginning
of this bring it full circle when it's
all said and done what i think we want
to say at the end of the day
is that these words all need to abscond
away out of our vocabulary to the
bahamas absolutely i couldn't agree more
although one word that i am obsessed
with and i have adopted is chugi it's
what the kids say for that is not cool
it's out of style and it ain't happening
so i guess all those sayings are now
choogie so that's it
[Music]